you guys have a wealth of material to
work with here two books the real people
the script Felix do you use everything
at once is there anything you found
yourself leaning on more than the others
yeah I think a little bit of everything
as you said although I think it's really
in a pre-production process that like
you are these for me I try to use all
that as you said in the books and
talking with Nick and working with Felix
and Steven then once once it gets going
it's not about being entertaining but
it's about kind of letting it all go in
and making it live I think Y started
with David as a person you know
obviously his his book informed a lot of
it's a story but yeah just getting to
know him a little bit on a personal
level and feeling the essence of the
type of guy he is what a big heart he
hasn't mmm how how emotional it must
have been for him to navigate this
situation so yeah I just started with
him I tried to you know key off of that
I feel like some of the pressure was
alleviated just because David and Nick
were part of the process from script
development and conversations I didn't
get to meet them unfortunately before
filming but I know you know Steve and
Timothy and Felix are very much had so
we had their blessings from the
beginning and that's a good thing as
opposed to be feeling like you're
hijacking someone's life and then
presenting it to them but that would be
a bit more nerve-wracking but still we
wanted to get it right they were so open
and generous and sharing their stories
seems like you had great leadership in
Felix I'm a very big broken circle
breakdown fans so going into this with
those expectations
I'm not surprised it's as powerful as it
is so how was it working with him and
maybe if particularly why was he the
right director to spearhead all this he
approaches these very heavy subjects
with so much love and care that even
films you know like his prior film it
it's same it's it's very it's very
heartbreaking but he finds he finds time
within his films for the nuanced and
even some humor there and and he didn't
he didn't try to nothing was done with
this like rigorous structure he was like
whatever feels most honest that's what
we're gonna do the best thing we did was
get together before we shot and just I
wouldn't even call it rehearsal we just
did we hung out we got to know one
another and we had lunches and we went
through the script and red-flagged parts
of it that didn't seem authentic and
and just got to know each other sort of
it became as much of a family as we
could before we started shooting so
there felt like there was a bit of
history once we started portraying these
characters
yeah I feel the same way and like you
said like a film like broken circle
breakdown that has all the emotional
it's overwhelming as you say and um and
he's you know these days movies are
human based emotion based like so as you
said he's coming over with ideas for
different takes as it relates to the
intimacy but you know Trust is always
the biggest thing with your director and
it's easy when they already have a piece
of work you can look at and go well this
is this we'd be lucky if we can strike a
similar tone between this and that movie
now I have two soundtracks that I could
just listen to music really plays a
powerful party both said that to feel
like sighs yeah that the soundtracks
amazing he's like oh it doesn't change
that much when you guys saw it had like
what were there any misconceptions about
dealing with addiction that released I
mean there are many of them but is there
any in particular that really stuck with
you that you hope that people can walk
away from this movie having a firmer
understanding yeah I mean it's not like
it's not a pretty picture of like you
know sex drugs rock and roll it's like
it's it's it's not fun and I think
that's what the film does so such a
beautiful job at and that it's not it's
not about having
moral lapse of character or judgment
it's it's it's disease so if we can
approach it that way and take shame out
of it then maybe people might be more
apt to get help sooner it's just it's
more complex than I think a lot of
people understand and it's there's
there's no right or wrong there's a lot
of gray area and I I I'm hoping that
that's what the the film depicts no
addiction doesn't discriminate and it
affects anyone and everyone and if you
know the most everyone knows someone
it's going through a version of this so
yeah we just hope it's a contemporary
reflection of what unfortunately a lot
of people are going through